oh alex young
it's up to him to keep it close the way
the diamondbacks offense has struggled
not a big safety net out there gonzo for
these pitchers
it really isn't prime el toppa you will
lead it off for colorado
this is a bouncer back to the mound alex
has got it
away in the first here's a guy you never
want to face right trevor story
this guy has really hit the diamondbacks
since he became
a major leaguer trevor drives the ball
towards right center field it's going to
go all the way and bang off the wall at
the 413 sign
story hits second he's thinking three
and he's going to get there without a
throw
trevor's story with his second triple of
the year
rockies with a first inning threat
here's oronato how about this he is 2
for
31 with runners in scoring position and
this
is down the left field line and it's
fair into that corner
so nolan brings story around and nolan
has his first
extra base hit on the road this year
again i can't believe i'm saying that
but uh what a wonderful time for it
and now a walk to charlie blackman two
one one out for matt kim
this ball crushed to deep left field get
up and it's off the corner of the fence
orinata will come home and the rockies
lead it two to nothing and i'm sure the
last
four days have been agonizing for hermod
because he's coming off a
very tough outing gave up ten earned
runs in five
innings and this ball is lined right at
tapia
makes the catch here's katel marte
hitting 328.
there's a fly ball into left center
field and that's going to get down
and go to the wall extra bases hamson
gets it back
in and marta is standing at second base
with a double 12 you get the time run up
here now that'll be starly martay
jammed him with the ball that's rolled
to first base
easy play for josh fuentes it's the
second out as cattell martay gets to
third
o2 pitch jammed him and it's rolled to
second brendan rogers has got it over to
first to retire the side the double does
no damage
christian walker leads it off against
demon marquez there's a drive to left
field by walker and
back-to-back knights with a home run
christian it's 2-1 oh was that loud off
the bat john james getting a start
tonight in right field
john jay gives one a ride hits it deep
to right field
blackman looking up and john jay has
tied the ball game
a pair of solo diamond back home runs in
the second that was a little unexpected
right there but the dive acts are sure
gonna take that here's garrett hamson
hamson has had good success against
the diamondbacks in his career swaying
in a drive to left field
back on the ball peralta it is over and
out of here
garrett hampson uncorks one to left and
the rockies get
back in the lead and now they're full of
diamondbacks you've got
walker at third escobar at second and
i'm headed first they're loaded for jay
john jay lifts it deep to center field
hampson backing up
he's still backing up he's on the track
under the home run porch
and this will get walker home the game
is tied well marcus walks
his second of the inning third of the
game and again the bases are loaded and
here is cattell marte
swing in a high fly ball this will stay
in the yard blackman makes the catch
in right field and airbond marquez
limits the damage to one run
and with two outstanders escobar that
runner at sega with two outs and runners
in scoring position
0 for three tonight oh for their last 22
swag and a miss he
got him with the breaking ball on a
night when his fastball
was not there airmon marcus keeps the
rockies tied
first and third and two outs drew butera
scheduled but daniel murphy is going to
pinch it there's a fly ball to left [ __ ]
and the ending right at peralta david's
there
he's got it two-handed catch murphy
arizona with a runner at third and two
outs here in the sixth
diamondbacks with two outs and runners
in scoring position
over four tonight and oh for their last
23
swang and a miss he got him with a
breaking ball
arizona over 10 so far in the clutch
tonight
now story representing the go-ahead run
down at second base well now an rbi
chance for arenado
and this ball is lifted to deep left
peralta on the move and the corner can't
get it fair ball
trevor is going to score easily and
nolan will have himself his second
double of the ball game
and the rockies retake the lead four to
three
bases loaded two outs now mcmahon's
going to come up
and ban for brendan rodgers the ball
gets away from the catcher kelly
coming in to score nolan aronado and the
rockies build on their lead it's now
five to three diamondbacks with two outs
and
runners in scoring position tonight 0
for 5 and 0 for their last 24
swinging a grounder left side taken by
arenado sets and guns him out across the
diamond
and that'll do it for the d backs in the
seventh daniel bart he's in the ball
game looking for his third save the
diamondbacks down their last stop for
all the steps in
the line drive left field base hit here
comes starling to score
it's five to four rbi single by peralta
keeps this one going
and the bases are loaded ahmed is the
batter two strikes on nicomez the
arizona shortstop
swag and a miss he got him and that's
the ball
game daniel barge strikes out nick
ahmed with the bases loaded